guys timepiece in the background
Elsa from my frozen but anyways I got a
debate club for your Asus Walmart or
Target I mean you know Walmart you go
you go double he goes on yeah good point
sir doctor Parisi
hey I got clowned as a kid in elementary
school my mom called it tarjay uh-huh
like fancy yeah I kept calling it tarjay
escort calling Nick actually the place
where I got that couch I thought I was
missing pieces they were all there it
looks comfy perfect size too Nick good
call I'm getting black yeah never gonna
replace Dara we're like yeah you guys
gonna get a replacement for Derrick or
it's just Kat it's hard to usually joke
against are we doing this show and
you're rocking the blue Cortez oh yeah
my my dad that was in prison for 17
years did he get busted for fighting
fish for drugs
did he really what kind of drugs was it
my dad was around when the crack
epidemic was going through slanging that
crack slaying that crack was it was a
gang member he wasn't really into the
gangs he was more so into like the drug
that the money and how much time did he
get he did so he has a crazy story so he
did 13 years he studied law and got
himself out of prison Wow
yeah so he's smart gives it just yeah so
because he got he got life for attempted
murder but he didn't do it
yeah but yes so he studied long enough
drugs found out the system [ __ ] up and
not only did my daddy release but
a bunch of other inmates got whoa yeah
sure pal that's what I guess when you
get live someone specific has to sign
off for it and that person did it so my
dad caught that now yeah it's like a
we're like we're building a relationship
did he still do drugs or anything
are they still dudes clean now yes clean
out yeah it's doing good was he using
drugs or he was just selling during I'm
selling it yeah yeah I mean it just
wasn't a lot of stuff for a black coat
there was a lot of stuff for black men
to sit they didn't have a lot of
business opportunity though you know you
got it you know what I'm saying I get
that I don't think when I was growing up
they didn't have like a lot of black
guys that were like doctors in our town
and stuff like that or like business
owners nothing drugs was like a easy
thing you could sell you know he said
when the crap he said was crazy the same
yeah he said you had two chances in like
seven out of the ten houses either
someone's doing it or selling it damn
that's how crazy if that's what you're
surrounded by you can get involved in
the business yeah what are you just tell
me that's just smoking crack and not in
but not a businessman Club the last got
100 Walmart or Target Oh Oh targets a
little fancier I'm more of a tour J guys
my mom called it but RJ's more for women
I feel like women more go to Target
anybody could go to Walmart you go to
Walmart to get a boat you can go to
Walmart to get a Bible
I feel like more meth addicts would dig
Walmart it's more kind of like it's
free-for-all yeah Walmart's a kind of
place if you're in a smaller area like
and you go to the Walmart it's kind of
like something to do we're all the same
also Walmart's are just kind of flea
markets got their [ __ ] together you know
yeah it's kind of like the clothing
section I always kind of liked it they
always had like Florida State gear and
stuff they always had like kind of a
couple of colleges and stuff yeah they
did I get Christmas you go get that you
get your brother says you can always get
an Oklahoma Sooners shirt yeah yeah
Crimson Tide you can only get two random
teams yeah you could get Hanes socks I
like that I like both but I'm more of a
tarjay man
yeah my son loves target yeah I guess
target looks a little bit more organized
it's smaller I feel like it's small at
Walmart's massive man you get exhausted
walking that thing you can get to
hydrate it in there you'll find people
just [ __ ] passed out people
unconscious sitting in lawn chairs yeah
yeah that's one thing I do like well you
can get it you can get to like the
second or third realm in there and you
can somebody [ __ ] I'm not Walmart beyond
yeah yeah did they lost somebody huh can
like brewing their own water right
cooking steaks on it dude it was crazy
because they do like ever like before
every shift they do this like weird
chant I can't tell it really but they do
this like weird chance I don't know it's
awkward but yeah I last about a week
really yeah
what didn't you like about it now why'd
you only last a week I mean I was just
[ __ ] I was like what the [ __ ] my it
was I don't just seem to Coulter sue me
more than Walmart cult
yeah that's what it seemed like what how
did you get out of there dude it takes
forever to get out of there here's the
thing though is that Walmart
I love Walmart I think if I could go
back in time and work somewhere I would
work at Walmart for a couple months
really I loved it man I've worked at
Home Depot I could see you at Home Depot
yeah with that launch cape on yeah and
you eat the churros
[Laughter]
can't start with your break dude dude
Costco to Costco has some good food man
the pizza
I'm sure OHS I don't go to Costco but I
do sometimes I used to go to Walmart and
they're good shrimp scampi I always
thought that Costco is an elite club and
get you in I know can you yeah I get you
plus one I'll go in yeah all right I'll
take Nick Thanks
Walmart allows people to tamp in their
parking lot for like travelers and stuff
I did it when I moved out here in my car
Wow
you didn't have any advice for the guy
Walmart if you should looking for a
place to see sleep Walmart I love that I
didn't know that I've always wondered
too I'm the dude it's like oh I'll go
parking like a scary area and just be
real quiet
I'm just working from the house and
figure it out I like to know Hooters
parking lot did you yeah I could see you
doing that they're in an Impala really
yeah another bloody nose for what were
you were they doing like a grand opening
or some in the morning no you would be
the first one in bloody nose I don't
know my nose won't stop bleeding I'll
never forget that Oh probably because of
any one of your life paths pro football
you like at that point the CT he has to
if I can really be setting in you're
sitting outside of a Hooters for the
nose or it was trying to drain out what
do you get Britten's like I'm gonna
block it
[Music]
nothing
[Music]